monster hunter rise was released back in
march of 2021 and with a score of nine
from us here at gamespot and a
metacritic of 88 i think it's safe to
say the game was a critical success and
now we're getting sun break the massive
new expansion to rise that features a
new setting new monsters and new ways to
take them down here's everything we know
so far about monster hunter rise sun
break
[Music]
monster hunter rise sunbury contains a
whole new story that picks up directly
from where the events of the main game
left off a sense of calm has finally
fallen over kimura village but
unfortunately it doesn't last long while
fighting off the cause of that
disturbance you encounter a knight of
the royal order named theorain together
with fiorine you sail off to elgato
outpost to investigate why monsters from
the kingdom are becoming more aggressive
and invading other areas this new
narrative will have you and fellow
hunters facing off against three
powerful new creatures known as the
three lords
elgato is a far off outpost that acts as
sun breaks new home base here hunters
will get to meet a whole new cast of
npcs who can assist in crafting and
sending you off on brand new quests some
of what you'll encounter within elgato
consist of the merchant shop where you
can craft health potions antidotes and
more from materials that you've gathered
however if you don't have time to pick
up resources on your adventures or
you're just a couple short the merchant
also has some in stock that you can buy
how convenient the blacksmith can help
you craft new gear from parts rewarded
upon quest completion this is also where
you can research new pieces upgrade your
weapons and outfit your buddies the
kimura tea shop is great for sitting
down for a meal and gaining bonuses
using the game's dango system this
system provides useful skills that are
different from the ones you get from
charms and armor the tea shop can also
be a great spot to craft items such as a
well done steak elgato outpost is also
where you can accept quests in the new
master rank difficulty which can be more
challenging than the base game seven
star hunts but when you're not busy
preparing you'll be out hunting in one
of sunbreak's new destinations each of
which offer new challenges to overcome
unique terrain to consider as well as
new materials and endemic life to
collect one of these locations is the
citadel area that features snowy peaks
lush forests and an abandoned fortress
right at the center
sunbreak will include different types of
monsters for the player to hunt this
includes aurora somnicanth which
releases a constant chilling mist that
threatens to freeze anything that gets
too close its abilities also allow it to
glide across icy terrain and exhale a
powerful ice breath attack magma
almadron is the opposite and instead
prefers the heat of the lava caverns and
augments its attacks with molten stone
to overwhelm the players meanwhile the
elder dragon malzino acts as the
commanding force behind the mysterious
swarm of parasitic entities that capture
and absorb the energy of their prey in
combat malzino's attacks are inspired by
the vampire using its blood blight
status to determine whose life force
will run out first if the hunter fails
malzino evolves into a stronger monster
in addition monster hunter rise will
also see the return of flying wyvern
seregios or the thousand edge dragon
which is best known for its high flying
maneuvers sharp blade scales coating its
body and a bleed status that can affect
players and if that wasn't enough
sunbreak also adds more powerful master
ranked versions of the monsters that
appeared in the base game monsters like
agnosome have a new backstep and
somersault attack while t-rex can combo
from a bite into a spin attack in order
to combat these new threats sunbreak
will introduce a new ability called
switch skill swap switch skill swap
enables hunters to assign switch skills
to two different loadouts which can be
changed on the fly during a hunt players
who find themselves under attack while
performing the ability can also perform
a swipe of aid in any direction to avoid
danger or simply to reposition for a
continued assault but be aware that
these evasive maneuvers cause stamina
when used switch skills are registered
to a red swap scroll and blue swap
scroll and can be alternated with
weapons drawn or put away monster hunter
rise sunbreak also introduces a new type
of quest called follower quests which
are single player only hunts that allow
you to accept and complete quests with
your favorite story characters to deepen
your bond with them capcom explained
that each follower has their own
specialization and can assist players in
battling by recovering their health
placing traps and riding monsters and
while the followers can be very helpful
in battle the quest does not depend on
their status so don't stress too much if
they fall in battle because it doesn't
count towards the failure condition of
that quest
similar to the base game monster hunter
rise sun break will include the ability
to play online or locally with up to
three of your friends once you're
connected with other players you can
embark on some quests together if
another player chooses a quest that you
haven't unlocked in your game yet you
will still be able to join them you'll
be able to keep rewards and materials
that you've earned but these quests
won't be marked as completed for you
[Music]
being an expansion to monster hunter
rise sunbreak will only be available on
the same platforms as the base game this
includes nintendo switch and pc via
steam capcom has said the game's update
will be around 13 gigabytes for all
players that want to access online
features but the studio didn't specify
if that number was for switch pc or both
monster hunter rise will be released on
june 30th 2022 and fans will have five
options for purchasing it the regular
digital edition costs 40 bucks while the
50 deluxe edition will include a handful
of bonus content such as new armor sets
gestures and hair stops for those who
are new to monster hunter you can take
advantage of the monster hunter rise
plus sun brake set that includes the
base game as well there will also be a
double deluxe version to the set as well
that includes bonus items for both the
base game and the expansion these two
versions aren't available for digital
pre-order but will be available for
purchase on release day in the physical
department there is a collector's
edition that offers the same digital
rewards as the deluxe edition as well as
some physical loot that includes a
sticker pack enamel pen steelbook case
and a malzino amiibo all players who
pre-order any version of the game will
get the loyal dog and striped cat armor
sets for their palamu and paliko
companions it will also be three
malzino-inspired amiibo for switch
players which will also unlock special
armor sets for palomut and paliko
companions and there you have it
everything we know so far about monster
hunter ryze sunbreak from the new
threats like elder dragon malzy notes to
the new features like switch skill swap
and follower quest you're gonna have a
ton of things to do when sun break
becomes available let us know what
you're doing to prepare for this
expansion in the comments below and make
sure you're subscribed to gamespot for
all the latest on monster hunter rise
[Music]
oh
[Music]
you